[Music]
godzilla versus gum has now been
released in the us
and also the rest of the world so the
first question that comes to mind is
where are all the other titans
the movie was a really good one but it
was really a big disappointment that we
didn't get to see
methuselah behemoth cilla and the others
either in action or just walking about
doing their thing when no one is looking
many of them were supposedly heading off
to skull island as per the news
clippings in the end credit scenes
of kotm and some of them were going to
their own natural habitat to live
peacefully
for the rest of their lives we were kind
of hoping we would see at least one or
two of them
in skull island causing havoc and
therefore getting into a fight with kong
but as we know now the place is
uninhabitable
so let us see why the other titans were
not in godzilla vs gong
let's get to it first off let's start
with the queen of the monsters daitanus
mosura
well it was obvious why she wasn't in
godzilla vs gong after being
disintegrated by monster zero's gravity
beams
but as we saw in the news clippings
there was a mothra egg that was
discovered in southern china after king
of the monsters by monarch
however there was no reincarnation of
mothra in godzilla vs kong which was
quite a
bummer maybe because it might take many
years for the act to actually mature
and the larva to hatch out from it to me
that's the only good explanation for her
absence
so next we have the fire demon rodan
news clippings during the credits scenes
reveal that
rodin had flown to and made a nest in
the volcano north of fiji
and his presence has attracted thousands
of spectators
and since rodan is another titan that
has the potential to defy
or stick to his own terms unless
physically defeated by his opponent
my best guess is that rodan would have
only been nesting and really had no
interest in the fight between godzilla
and kong
and since the titans were not just a
group of animals but
also a very highly intelligent group of
kaiju
then rodan would just have waited and
rested on top of a habitat
a volcano right back in a similar place
as to how he started
and waited for one of them to finish the
other
then comes methuselah according to
legend methuselah destroyed a village in
munich
way back in the middle ages then settled
down to sleep on its wreckage
where a forest grew on him and he was
assumed to be a mountain until monarch
discovered his true origins methuselah
was created to show that
the titans can be a part of the natural
world to camouflage himself and hide in
plain sight
to be honest methuselah did seem to look
like a titan that is very old
and that naps a lot to be fair he
actually had a mountain with
trees growing on top of him i think with
monster zero out of the way and no alpha
calls for him to destroy
anything he would have likely just gone
back into hibernation
then what about behemoth a benign
protector with an almost symbiotic
relationship with the environment
behemoth's presence breeds life into the
previous barren environments
as the massive amounts of its droppings
become a nutrient
rich fertilizer that can regrow entire
rainforests to help restore
the balance of nature and strengthen
earth's immune system
this titan was another one that was
awakened by monster zero and obeyed his
commands
behemoth was supposed to be a titan that
was used as a war beast by an ancient
civilization
but now he could have either gone stuck
in an unstable skull island
or gone down to the hollow earth or gone
back to hibernation in brazil but either
way we didn't see him
in godzilla vs kong although there were
toys that teased his presence there
liars now we come to silla the giant
armour to fall apart titan with black
coloration and six very long bony and
lightly haired legs
it was another fan favorite and was not
seen again in godzilla vs kong
it was one of the major titans that
arrived in boston to bow down to
godzilla as the king of the monsters
and therefore was spared and not
attacked by him news reports later
mentioned that monarch has confirmed
sylla's greek origins
and it can be seen that cilla has become
one of the most popular and famous
titans to humanity
according to the report cilla is having
a positive impact on the environment
by emitting enough liquid nitrogen to
slow down the melting of
the ice in the antarctica and
stabilizing the world's sea levels
godzilla vs kong wouldn't have had any
real
motivations facility to come out of
antarctica
meaning why would she just come out and
either attack
comb or godzilla take sides obviously
she would be killed in the process by
either of the alpha tyrants
which means she is just hibernating back
in antarctica or maybe
she has taken the route back to the
hollow earth in antarctica
and then we have the last island that
made an appearance in king of the
monsters
and this one is the muto queen or barb
to be honest we weren't really expecting
her to be seen in godzilla vs kong as
their species
was already a big part of godzilla 2014
and the comics godzilla aftershock
and yet seen again in kotm it would be
kind of
moot to show her and not the other ones
here in godzilla vs kong
the muto queen also known as bob would
have probably been killed by the g-man
as she is a natural enemy of his species
looks like going to boston was a bad
trip for bob
so what about mukele and bembe typhon
baphomet leviathan the kraken my guess
is that they would have either gone back
to hibernation
or the ones with the flight capabilities
or swimming would have gone to skull
island and made the island unstable and
thus letting the perpetual storm
to take over the entire island as well
so anyway that's about it
the titans were never seen in godzilla
vs com
maybe in a future video or maybe in a
future movie from the monsterverse if
it is continued so anyway
do like for support subscribe to be a
part of the minecube family
and smash that notification bell for
regular updates on new video uploads
right here on minecube take care fam